usa los puntos 0 0 45 y x
en la recta azul de la gráfica para
completar la ecuación y entre x es igual
a nuestra incógnita esta es nuestra
línea azul y aquí están los puntos que
nos menciona 0 045 y x que nos piden
escribir la ecuación de la recta en la
forma de igual a mx m recordemos que es
la pendiente y la pendiente se define
como el cambio en jake con respecto al
cambio en x entonces vamos a usar estos
elementos que nos dan vamos a marcar
cuál es la pendiente
vamos a tomar de estos puntos que
conocemos del 4.5 vamos a marcar aquí
nuestro cambio en el cambio esta delta
de aquí este triangulito es la letra
griega delta y significa cambiar
entonces este es el cambio en y aquí
abajo vamos a poner en otro color
nuestro cambio en x del punto 0 0 hasta
este otro punto
esto es nuestro cambio en x delta x y
ahora podemos escribir no está pendiente
m está m de acá m es igual a nuestro
cambio en g entre nuestro cambio en x
delta x muy bien cuál es este valor
bueno si partimos de este punto a este
punto del cambio que es de 0 a 5
así que nuestra del taller es de 5 esto
es igual a 5 aquí arriba y cuál es el
cambio en x segundos ya lo vieron
partimos del origen de este 0 y
avanzamos 4 lugares hasta este punto
cero a cuatro la diferencia s 4 entonces
nuestra delta x es 4 no está pendiente
es de 54 pero nos están pidiendo que lo
expresamos en esta forma como sabemos la
pendiente en una recta va a ser
constante nunca va a cambiar cualquier
triángulo rectángulo este recordemos que
acabamos de hacer es un triángulo
rectángulo este es un ángulo recto ya
que está el cambio en y es una línea
perfectamente vertical y el cambio en
ese es una línea perfectamente
horizontal se intersectan formando un
ángulo recto y cualquier triángulo
rectángulo que formamos usando cualquier
par de puntos sobre esta recta va a
tener esta proporción del paciente delta
x igual van a ser constantes así que
ahora es cuando usamos este otro punto
que nos dan x coma ya que es otro punto
aleatorio de la recta así que ahora en
otro color voy a poner cuál es la
diferencia
él está bien pero ahora de este punto de
acá
hacia mi eje x más o menos por acá este
es mi cambio en que también pero ahora
tomando en cuenta este punto x como ayer
me cambio en que va a ser este punto y
aquí me del calle es igual a este valor
de ya que no estoy fijándome exactamente
cuáles es un punto aleatorio menos este
otro valor enriquecer 10 menos ser ahora
el cambio en x pues va a estar de este
punto de x de este punto x como jane
hacia el origen que es el que estoy
tomando este punto 0 como hacer y ahora
de éste me cambio en x delta x es igual
al valor x que tengo acá
20 que es el punto que se tomando aquí
el origen x menos ser así que esta delta
y entre delta x esta nueva del taller
que acabo de encontrar entre delta x
delta x
estas son iguales a 10 0 entre delta xx
menos ser muy bien pero sabemos que la
pendiente es constante en toda esta
recta así que este valor es igual a este
5 cuartos de acá entonces esto va a ser
igual a 5 cuartos lo ponemos con los
colores que corresponden para que veamos
de dónde viene este valor
pues para dejarlo en esta forma de iu y
x pues vemos que aquí ya menos 0 pues va
a ser porque le estamos restando nada
igual aquí en x entonces podemos dejarlo
como y entre x es igual a 5 cuartos
y para dejarlo de esta manera vamos a
multiplicar todo por equis me va a
quedar y es igual a cinco cuartos de
equis y aquí está la ecuación que nos
piden de esta manera ahora vamos a ver
la imagen de la respuesta correcta y
aquí está la respuesta a la imagen de la
respuesta que pusimos ya igual a cinco
cuartos de equis y aquí está correcto
así que nuestro análisis estuvo bien nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo